hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today
maintain a question from Virginia who's
one of my newsletter readers so she
wrote in saying she's 48 years old
single mother her her husband or
ex-husband I guess is not given any kind
of child support she hasn't had her
degree at she's studying part-time but
she wants to be able to follow her dream
and do something that she's really
passionate about and wanted my advice on
how to get going so it's a great
question I'm very sorry here but
situation hopefully that resolves itself
and now you're able to move on to a much
better life and and you know build
something that you can build around your
passion so my advice for you and this is
something that's asked a lot by a lot of
my readers is how do I find my passion
how do I build a business around and and
have the confidence to take that leap
what i would do to get started is make a
list of all the things that you are
really excited about and passionate
about things that you would do in your
part time spare time I know you may not
have a lot of your single mom when
you're studying and you have a job too
but what do you like to do it in your in
your part time and try to marry that
with what can you do to help people if
you're looking at starting the business
and being successful you have to be able
to provide a product or service that
provides a lot of value to other people
right they're going to be the ones
paying you so you're you may really love
playing computer games all day long but
if you're not adding tangible value to
other people then you're not going to be
able to really build successful business
off of it so that would be step number
one I then also look at what are some
frustrations that you solve in your own
life that maybe other people could could
have that help as well so through your
you know of course if your life had a
lot of experience you probably had a lot
of ups and downs through those down
times what are some of the biggest most
painful problems that you had to go
through and how can you potentially help
other people solve those problems the
bigger the pain is the more painful it
is for somebody the bigger the
frustration the more they're going to
want to pay you to help them solve it so
that's a key with any business if you
work if you're targeting the pain
a problem or frustration of somebody
it's going to be easier to build a
business off of it so we're starting
with something that we're really
passionate about with something or
something that there's a there's a pain
involved and we're starting with
something that we feel we can help other
people a lot of entrepreneurs make the
mistake of just trying to start a
business to make money and it's the
wrong way to go about it because if you
look at the most successful famous
entrepreneurs look at anybody who got
started they rarely started because they
wanted to make a lot of money it's
because they had a strong passion for
what they were doing they wanted to
change the way things were done in their
industry or they want to have a
meaningful impact on the people that
they were connecting with that's what
make them get started and that's what
made them keep going through all the
hard times and certainly business isn't
easy it can be very rewarding can be a
lot of fun it can be you know bringing a
lot of money if you stick with it but
there's a lot of hard times to get a
company off the ground and you're only
going to do it if you're really
passionate about what you're doing so I
try to make that list of ideas once
you've narrowed it down to see the top
three to five ideas I try to commit to
doing some more research on it so I
commit to doing at least an hour of
research on the internet for each idea
and also commit to going to the
bookstore or local library to do more
research on the idea now you can
probably find everything you need on the
internet so why would you go to a
bookstore library the reason is actually
getting out of your house going and
making that trip and get in a babysitter
or whatever you need to do to go there
commits you two doing a little bit on
that business and if you're not willing
to commit to going to do what trip to
the bookstore you're probably not going
to be able to make that business a
success right that's a that's a pretty
minimal equipment and you have to take
some seriously big commitments to make
that business take off so if there's
some ideas on there that you don't want
to go and make that trip for you can
probably scratch them off the list then
I look at which idea is that you just do
the bare minimum along and which ones
that you actually go out and really
spend a lot of time trying to figure out
so if the you know the assignment is
into one hour of internet research in
one hour at a bookstore which ideas did
you actually go and just do an hour on
and which idea is that you go way above
and beyond you kind of got lost in it
because you were so excited and
passionate about
I got so many new ideas from it and you
just poured your heart into it that's
the one that you want to really focus on
to build your business and the ones
we're just doing the bare minimum again
if you're an entrepreneur and you're
just doing the bare minimum you're not
going to have success you have to go way
above and beyond especially to launch a
new business so the one that you're
really focused on and you spent all that
extra time on that's probably the one
where you would want to start to to
build your company around from there
it's just starting to talk to customers
getting their feedback trying to build a
service that can help solve the problems
and invest the cash flow that you have
coming in and to continue to grow your
business but that's how it would start
up how to find my passion how to start a
business around that's something I'm
really excited about so hopefully that
helps again with your situation I hope
this can be a new opportunity for you to
discover yourself and live the best life
possible for yourself for those of you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up it makes me want to
do more of these for you and if you have
a question about finding your passion or
about your business feel free to leave
in the comments below I always read
those we've how to respond to as many as
I can so thank you and we'll see you on
the next episode
you